[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine handball les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux furent ont subi
une nouvelle défaite en championnat de
nationale 2 et saint quentinois se sont
inclinés face à toul carantec plus
d'informations à suivre cross-country
les championnats de france se sont
déroulés ce week-end au mur ou un
événement qui a attiré plus de 15000
personnes notre journaliste justin
brasier était sur place course à pied
l'éco trail de paris programmé ce samedi
plusieurs cours sont organisés au départ
des yvelines notamment à 80 km qui
reliera l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines à la tour eiffel
plus d'informations à suivre l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tb 78
on commence donc par du handball et
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
avait une belle occasion de remonter
dans la première partie du classement de
nationale 2 mais les îles montaigne se
sont inclinés face à toul carantec à
domicile ce week-end reportages des
images de céline charme une défaite au
goût amer pour montigny le bretonneux
après une entame de match délicate
lésigny montait n'ont pas réussi à
s'imposer à domicile face à tous le
carantec lors de la 16e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 score final
30 à 24 on a essayé de rectifier un peu
le tir en mettant on a demandé un peu de
temps quelques consignes malheureusement
en a pas ils n'ont pas été respectées et
l'équipe adverse a su justement jouer
sur nos points faibles
voilà donc on y voit il voulait pas
qu'on revient j'étais d'ailleurs sur le
plan psychologique que nous on essaie
justement comme le score et ça c'est
très très on va dire c'est très dur pour
les filles est en fait en soit on s'est
battu jusqu'à la fin c'est le sentiment
qu'il va falloir retenir on aime quand
même fait une remontée sur la fin donc
ça nous a permis de garder l'espoir
jusqu'au bout et de garder les coeurs
des supporters jusqu'au bout qu'ils
veulent qui virevoltait un petit peu
mais
les décès sont principalement avec cette
défaite les féminines de montigny le
bretonneux sont désormais 8e avec un
bilan de 6 victoires 1 nuls et 9
défaites en 16 matches disputés chaque
match est important étant donné notre
position c'est à dire que
nous sommes classés dans la 2ème partie
du classement notre objectif c'est de
remonter sur la première partie puisque
c'est toujours mieux d'être en sécurité
va se battre jusqu'au bout pour le
maintien donc c'est dur très dur sur une
poule très très de danse bur tout le
monde peut battre tout le monde dreux la
semaine dernière un malheur il en a été
chercher la victoire à taulé et cette
semaine ils viennent gagner ici donc
voilà c'est simple prochaine rencontre
pour les inhumant tel le samedi 19 mars
à domicile face à lanester un autre gros
morceau l'équipe est classée 5e du
championnat coup de projecteur à présent
sur les autres résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les yvelines comme chaque
lundi au presque bixente mère ayant
senti steban est à mes côtés bonsoir
bixente xiam heureux de vous retrouver
en tout cas merci ça fait plaisir de
revenir alors on va parler football oui
et en effet il ne reste en national de
plus que neuf matchs au fc versailles
pour valider son excellente saison
victorieux 1 0 contre vannes ce week-end
les joueurs de youssef chebbi ont
accentué leur avance sur leurs
poursuivants principal le ces chartes
qui s'est incliné 3 0 à plabennec huit
points c'est l'avant ce que compte
désormais le leader versailles et sur le
sécheur très le blois foot 41 on le
rappelle deuxième du championnat la
réserve de lorient ne peut pas monter en
division supérieure
dans cette division michael ealy a aussi
poissy qui joue pour sa survie
les pisciacais vont mieux et au terme
d'un match où tout s'est emballé dans la
seconde période il remporte une seconde
victoire de suite
score 3 2 avec un but libérateur de
gassama à la 93e minute nous avions
d'ailleurs rencontré le président du
club olivier c'est vésuve qui nous parle
du maintien de son équipe écoutez la mi
temps contre plabennec étaient deux
points derrière nous alors qu'on joue
quand même le maintien on perdait 2-0 à
la mi-temps je leur ai juste dit un mot
les garçons y en a qui se bat contre des
armes ici c'est pas un combat on n'est
pas en guerre mais néanmoins j'attends
de vous de relever la tête on a gagné 3
2 comme si c'était un signe c'est
curieux donc ça nous a relancés un peu
on a senti cette joie dans le vestiaire
et donc ça va être un combat jusqu'à la
fin de saison bien sûr ça c'est
l'interview était la semaine dernière
michael et poissy a enchaîné il donc une
deuxième victoire de rang sur le même
score 3 buts à 2 une vraie bouffée d'air
frais pour les pisciacais qui sont à la
dixième position a eu longueurs de la
zone de relégation ça va bien en tout
cas ton secteur offensif pour poissy le
paris-nice s'est achevé hier bixente un
petit bilan de cet évènement passés par
les yvelines oui puisque les deux
premières des huit étapes sont parties
de notre département à mantes la ville
puis auffargis c'était dimanche 6 et
lundi 7 mars sans surprise le slovène
primoz straw gisha emporté la
prestigieuse cour jeudi sans surprise
mais qu'elle met quand même les
conditions de la dernière étape était
difficile et il faut savoir que c'était
son premier paris nice puisque primos
promis je viens à bout d'une petite
malédiction sur l'épreuve on ne se
rappelle qu'il avait chuté pendant
l'émission 2021 lors de la dernière
étape parmi les performances notables
des français deux victoires christophe
laporte sur la première étape à mantes
la ville et mathieu burbau d'eau jeune
coureur de total énergie en solitaire
sur la 6e étape entre courthézon et
aubagne bon bah ouais c'est de france et
michel t on pas ce repli oui avec un
petit mode d'avant de l'illinois léopard
et qui a été élu homme du match lors de
la victoire de l'équipe de france des
moins de 20 ans les jeunes d'imiter
leurs aînés pour ainsi dire une victoire
47 à 20 face au pays de galles pour le
tournoi jeunes des six nations et il n'y
a vaincu le tournoi des six nations en
rugby où il ya un autre très gros match
avait lieu dans le département plaisir
recevez tour et l'emporter 31 12 avec le
bonus offensif en prime dans la besace
quatrième victoire de suite pour les
plaisirs roi dans cette division de
fédérale 2 rien que ça ils reviennent
donc à quatre points seulement des
barrages pour la montée et il reste
quatre matches justement à jouer dont
leurs adversaires directs le creux le
club breton du rheu et on termine par
deux infos sportives autour de la ville
de trappes mais avec du basket tout
d'abord puisque trap est toujours
deuxième de sa division 2 nationale 3
victoires 69-66 ce week-end sur le
parquet de l'ice ptt caen ce sera
compliqué pour chercher le titre puisque
devant les trappistes se trouve le club
de levallois qui a 19 victoires en 19
matchs michael en bas de la division
marly le roi occupe la dernière position
avec une défaite 56 81 face à caen
hérouville il reste trois matches omar
ly choix pour se sauver ton teint contre
un concurrent direct barjouville enfin
mickaël je reviens sur trappe puisque le
club de taekwondo de la ville avait
plusieurs représentants aux championnats
de france ce week-end qui se déroulait
au stade gerland de bilan deux médailles
d'argent et une médaille d'or l'argent
pour un tout jeune prodige du club
trappistes miguel moncef à tout juste 16
ans il était surclassée en moins de 63
kilos en moins de 62 kg côté féminin
calida haddad s'est hissé à la deuxième
marche du podium également et la
médaille d'or pour inesta oui en
catégorie moins de 46 kg 40 kg bravo aux
représentants du club de le traiter de
trappes bravo et merci bixente pour
toutes ces précisions la semaine
prochaine vous serez titulaire dans
cette émission à ma place vous avez
présenté ce 7,8 sport attention je suis
de retour à la semaine d'après oui j'ai
hâte je vais essayer de vous remplacer
d'être digne de cette position michael
merci à vous qui j'étais bon courage
pour la semaine prochaine alors on va
ouvrir une page course à pied les
championnats de france de cross-country
étaient organisées pendant à trois jours
au mur ou un rendez vous qui a réuni
plusieurs milliers de personnes notre
journaliste justin brasier était sur
place regardez ce long format ce
dimanche 13 mars on se retrouve annie de
loisirs du val de seine pour les
championnats de france de cross-country
c'est la quatorzième fois cette année
que les championnats nationaux elles
sont accueillies dans le département et
des hiboux et la deuxième fois depuis
2000 qu'un vrai que la compétition se
déroule aux mureaux pourquoi avoir
organisé ces championnats de france aux
mureaux c'est la troisième fois que nous
revenons aux mureaux pour les champions
de france il y a un site extraordinaire
qui permet d'accueillir cette grande
population c'est champion de france et
le championnat le plus populaire de la
fédération donc il nous faut des lieux
qui sont capables d'accueillir et c'est
vrai que nous avons localement aussi en
club très performant grand paris seine
oise athlétisme et la ligue de
l'ile-de-france qui ont pu boney m
les 500 bénévoles donc il y avait toutes
les toutes les conditions étaient
réunies avec un nouveau parcours
d'ailleurs et je pense que depuis trois
jours on vit vraiment des moments
extraordinaires et tout le monde semble
satisfait de ce lieu donc là les murs au
t1 terre de cross finalement ça devient
une habitude depuis 2015 la poste en
2015 oui on peut dire que le mur hauteur
de crosse et puis nous avons une
municipalité qui est bien engagée caf
qui a fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
condition reçu dans les meilleures
conditions parfait et du coup un peu
plus globale qu'est ce que ça représente
pour les sportifs ce rendez vous et
c'est un rendez vous important
là vous savez c'est le cross c'est un
petit peu la base de toute la pratique
l'athlétisme et ça se pratique depuis de
nombreuses années puisque c'est le 130e
championnat de france donc c'est pas et
ça permet de réunir tous les clubs aussi
donc on a pratiquement toute la france
qui s'est réuni aujourd'hui aux mureaux
ça vient clôturer aussi la saison
hivernale l'athlétisme est un sport
d'été aussi et donc on clôture
aujourd'hui pratiquement la saison
dernière et justement il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont réunies on attend
combien on attendait combien d'athlètes
sur le week end alors très exactement
4825 qu'athlète mais si vous tenez
compte qu'il ya les dirigeants de clubs
les entraîneurs de public je pense que
sur le site aujourd'hui on doit tourner
autour de kazim les personnes quinze
mille personnes attendues en comptant le
public et les athlètes et les
organisateurs et et ces personnes
viennent d'où viennent de toute la
france vous disiez oui toute la france
et même de l'outre-mer donc c'est le
rendez vous national que tout le monde
attend on n'a pas pu l'organiser en 2000
vers à la cause du coc vite en 2021
l'organiser avant tout vent au mois de
novembre là on reprend un cycle normal
le cros et fin février début mars ça
vient clôturer la la fin de la saison
hivernale donc là ces trois jours on est
on est content on est fiers de reprendre
ça et ça se passe bien oui ça se passait
bien tout le monde est content écoutez
on espère que le temps encore un petit
peu te dire qu'on n'aura pas trop de
pluie mais bon le cross de toute façon
ça se court dans n'importe quelles
conditions l'île de loisirs a été
transformé pour l'occasion trois boucles
ont été dessinés sur le site une petite
1400 mètres une moyenne de 2000 et une
grande de 2400 mètres donc on les
reconnaît facilement la petite et jaune
la moyenne est verte et la grande et
rouge les départs et les arrivées sont
en blanc allaient mario margossian
hacker qui va aller chercher toutefois
joie est tout à son bonheur le titre de
championne de france du cross court ça
fait là aussi une sacrée championne de
france devant alice me tarde à je pense
que c'est un parcours qui est très
exigeant qui est très beau qui est très
vallonné on est sur un site qui est
merveilleux
vallonné donc on s'est servi de
2-2 toutes les bosses ça et puis même
des dévers et tout ça justement pour
pouvoir faire un beau parcours et là je
voudrais remercier notre ami jean
philippe guillot donc et le directeur
des services des sports david des
mureaux qui a fait un travail formidable
on a travaillé main dans la main pour
réussir à faire ce beau parcours est ce
que peut être des pièges à éviter des
pièges non parce qu'on les a tous envie
enlevé parce qu'ils ont donc tous les
cailloux et tout ça c'était en bus
parfois des cailloux c'est 100 kg impôts
pour pour pour dire et tous les pièges
ont été enlevés par contre comme les
coureurs on les aime bien on leur a mis
quelques difficultés comme je parlais
tout à l'heure du dévers inversé il ya
comme des virages qui sont assez serrés
on les a faits au combat pour que c'est
vrai ça glisse vraiment mais j'y reste
il ya beaucoup de relances quand même
beaucoup de montées beaucoup de
descentes voilà les piles et des verts
et donc l'arrêt la pluie elle est au
rendez vous et vous disiez c'est une
bonne chose finalement alors enfin alors
donc tout le monde me regardait avec des
gros yeux moi je voulais de la pluie là
tout le monde rhodia il pleut c'est
dommage non accroît ça se fait avec de
la pluie glacée donc la pluie est la
bienvenue le cross était déjà organisé
aux mureaux en 2015 quelle va être la
différence aujourd'hui alors la grosse
différence c'est que ce cross est très
visuel vous pouvez aller du point
baisser lire de l'est au point i calé à
l'ouest sans avoir une seule traversée à
passer et vous pouvez voir tout le
parcours en ayant juste une seule
traversée à passer en se mettant à
certains endroits on peut voir passer
jusqu'à cinq fois sans bouger on peut
voir passer les coureurs donc c'est
quelque chose de très visuel rihanna
vient en fait de faire le choix de la
courte acquis manon trappe et championne
ça ne va concerner le dossard jaune elle
double la mise après montauban les
mureaux personne ne pouvait le lui
contester bravo à elle c'est une sacrée
championne de france et bien sûr ici il
n'ya pas que des athlètes mais également
des passionnés et l'entourage venus
assister à la compétition pour
encourager les coureurs au total quinze
mille personnes étaient attendues sur
l'ensemble du week-end on va aller à
leur rencontre ce film moi je suis venu
aujourd'hui au bureau parce que j'ai mon
enfant qui est minime minimes 2 et qui
s'est qualifiée pour la première fois
sur la ligue aura été en tant que parent
on a envie de voir un petit peu ce que
donne un championnat de france puisque
tout le monde dit que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et puis bah voir son fils évolue là
dedans c'est c'est sympa
c'est grandiose un grand chemin tout les
tous les gens qui gardent les enfants
tous assez
l'arrimage tout de suite félicité un
format non
4825 athlètes se sont donnés rendez vous
sur le site du 11 au 13 mars parmi les
équipes représentées on retrouve blanc
tentative de saint quentin en yvelines
elle a envoyé 26 sportif
[Musique]
dans telle entente athlétique de saint
quentin en yvelines combien d'athlètes
sélectionnés donc moi je représente oui
le club de saint quentin on a la chance
cette année on a 26 athlètes qui ont été
sélectionnés et on a un athlète par
chacune des catégories donc des minimes
les plus jeunes jusqu'aux masters qui
sont plus de 35 ans
c'est à voir autant de battles est c'est
une reconnaissance un peu du travail qui
effectué pendant toute l'année même plus
boire plus cette année c'est vraiment
une belle reconnaissance avec les deux
années de qu'ovide qu'on vient de vivre
donc on a on a organisé les championnats
dans les yvelines donc ça nous a permis
de motiver des jeunes motivés des
équipes et c'est ça qui nous a amenés
aujourd'hui vraiment ce résultat avec 26
athlètes et justement le fait que le
championnat de france là soient
organisées dans les yvelines qu'est ce
que ça apporte pour le club qu'est ce
que ça vous fait pour l'équipe et pour
les athlètes ben pour le pour l'équipe
l'avantagé que c'est pas loin donc ça
fait un déplacement ont la possibilité
d'emmener pas mal de supporters donc là
en l'occurrence on doit avoir une
cinquantaine de supporters une trentaine
sont venus en bus pour supporter les
athlètes justement toute l'équipe est là
derrière pour encourager ils sont tous
venus il ya une grande cohésion dans
l'équipe ouailles à beaucoup de dents
dans le club c'est une cohésion de club
parce que l'équipe il y avait je pense
dans les supporters il ya forcément des
parents de d'athlète mais il ya aussi
des copains ou des amis qui font des
sports autres qui font du basket par
exemple ou qui font de l'athlétisme mais
pas forcément du cross qui font du
sprinter est du saut à la perche donc
c'est vraiment ce côté là où on arrive à
regrouper pour un championnat de france
et c'est super et pour les 26 donc
athlètes qui ont été sélectionnés venus
ici ça permet de gagner en expérience
surtout c'est bon je dirais peut-être un
honneur pour eux parce que il ya peu de
place c'est 300 athlètes au maximum sur
la france donc il faut c'est une place
qui gagne et il faut quand même se
battre il ya des championnats d'abord
départementaux après y'a régionaux et
après il ya un ter régionaux avant de
pouvoir accéder en finale ici en france
donc oui c'est je pense que pour un
athlète c'est un rêve quelle que soit la
place qu'il fait
c'est vraiment un rêve de pouvoir venir
sur des gens bien la france
[Musique]
et parmi les 26 athlètes sélectionnés de
l'entente athlétique de saint quentin en
yvelines et les a300 et jade le corps
elles ont participé à la course cadettes
de 11h35 ce dimanche 13 mars j'ai hâte
c'était quoi d'être à domicile
aujourd'hui bah justement c'est sait
quelque chose et vu que il enfin ma
famille est venue me voir du coup que
c'était à côté donc j'étais très
heureuse de les voir heureux quoi est-ce
que tu connaissais le parcours déjà
avant tu l'a découvert sur le moment
j'ai fait une super cross la semaine
dernière donc je connaissais déjà le
parcours et vu que ça fait plusieurs
fois que je cours pas ici mais du coup
j'ai l'habitude donc je connaissais le
parcours en avance ça te permet de
gagner en expérience malgré tout ce
championnat même si tu l'as déjà fait
même s'il a déjà remporté bah oui chaque
course est importante et
enfin ça ça crée des expériences et ça
nous ça nous chante jours ci en quelques
sorte
d'audit dans la catégorie cadette
aujourd'hui tu l'a remporté sa deuxième
victoire qu'est ce que ça te fait fierté
bah oui forcément c'est
j'ai pas trop quoi dire
je suis très heureuse
est ce que toi tu connaissais le
parcours au préalable oui je connaissais
pas du coup j'ai effet l'aspect cross
aussi
les lits faste à peu près le même
parcours et je m'entraîne ici avant donc
je connais bien des difficultés
peut-être sur ce parcours justement le
sable c'était très dur je trouvais et
sinon ça au niveau de ton classement du
coup tu arrives et combien ou est-ce que
tu est satisfaite de sa performance je
suis arrivé 22e et oui je suis très
satisfaite de ma performance
c'était attendait où tu tu aurais
préféré faire mieux je m'attendais pas
du tout parce que je visais top 30 et du
coup je m'attendais pas à faire ce
classement live très contente
[Musique]
puis
autour nuit
l'événement est en train tout doucement
de se terminer
dernière course prévue à 15h45 et ce
dimanche 7 mars et plus les résultats de
ces championnats de france de
cross-country sont à retrouver sur le
site internet de la fédération française
d'athlétisme
[Musique]
toujours au chapitre course à pied la
15e édition de l'eco trail de paris
programmé ce samedi 19 mars avec
plusieurs courses au programme dont un
80 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines coup de
projecteur sur ce rendez vous en pleine
nature avec l'un des organisateurs
jérôme toulouse c'est notre interview
express
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les contraigne c'est un événement qui a
été créée en 2008 par des amoureux de
courses nature et qui ont décidé
justement de créer un trade en région
parisienne et des courses nature aussi
avec avec plusieurs plusieurs
fondamentaux
c'était s'était mis justement dans l'adn
de l'événement de de vouloir faire
découvrir le patrimoine culturel
historique de la région d'île de france
c'était le le terrain de jeu des
fondateurs le dossier de sensibiliser à
toute la partie éco-responsabilité qui
n'est pas forcément de conscience
commune en 2000 en 2008 qui maintenant
fondamental on me dira pour pour tout le
monde et puis aussi de favoriser la
pratique du sport pour l'ensemble des
franciliens
donc samedi ce n'était pas forcément le
trade à cette époque là donc voila
c'était un vrai lancement en 2008 et
puis maintenant on a on a plusieurs là
plusieurs épreuves en a cinq épreuves de
trade qui vont du 10e 80 km et deux
épreuves de marche nordique de 17 18 km
c'est un parcours nature on assure le 80
km à peu près 92% du parcours qui se
fait dans les forêts est une toute toute
petite partie bitumée sûr sûr sûr
l'arrivée le 80 km lui va partir de
l'île et loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines leva river au premier étage de
la tour eiffel juste avant ça avance et
80 km par qu'on va passer par part donc
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ça va passer ensuite par
montigny bus au niveau du chef lieu du
château et puis après emprunté toutes
les forêts domaniales de l'ouest
c'est pour tout type de coureur
justement c'était la volonté la volonté
initiale c'était c'était de créer de
créer un événement on pouvait rassembler
le maximum de personnes possible donc
des sportifs aguerris comme des amateurs
sur sur l'éco trail aujourd'hui on a à
peu près de 40% de néophytes donc des
personnes qui n'ont soit jamais qu ils
soient jamais participé à un trail donc
on se rend compte de l'universalité
justement un petit peu de cet événement
on a des personnes qui viennent courir
un 10 km en une heure et demie deux
heures qui viennent découvrir la
pratique on adéquat qui vient de courir
à 80 kilomètres en cinq heures et demie
parce que c'était parce que ces deux
sportifs aguerris on continue à parler
de l'eco trail de paris nous avons avec
nous sur ce plateau un participant un
habitué de ce rendez vous si li diallo
bonsoir syli alors vous allez participer
à ce rendez vous pour la quatrième fois
cette fois-ci vous allez participer aux
45 km au départ du château de versailles
est ce que c'est un rendez vous
important pour vous qui êtes un habitué
des marathons dont je rappelle que vous
aurez fait plus de 300 dans votre vie
mais écoutez c'est c'est oui c'est très
important surtout pour nous qui habitons
dans la région puisque la l'épreuve la
plus longue par dix ans de chez nous à
quelques de trois kilomètres que de chez
moi donc je les fais trois fois est bon
mais cette fois ci je passerai de sai
pour faire 45 km alors il n'y avait plus
de places en jeu propre pour le
rendez-vous de 11 heures de l'île des
loisirs 50 ans limite du coup vous allez
faire le trajet de
montigny-le-bretonneux jusqu'à
versailles à pied et ensuite de les
faire et 45 km oui absolument donc je
vais active et de deux montres unis cela
pour la partie officielle et l'autre
pour la partie officielle donc je pense
faire au minimum
55 km minimes ans peut-être plus est-ce
que vous avez un objectif ou pas sûr sur
cette course
là oui mais
l'objectif en fait
c'est
la santé le bonheur et le portage c'est
de vous sait pas c'est le veut
l'objectif en fait habituellement enfin
nos ancêtres il coule comme nous mais
c'était quoi attraper les animaux en
fait on fait la même chose tous les
avantages en fait lieu cotrel du trail
part pour le marathon ce qui se passe en
bourse donc c'est beaucoup plus proche
des conditions des chasses et d'ailleurs
de l'eco trail de paris on passe dans
les forêts c'était les terrains de
chasse soit du roi soit 2 voilà c'est le
terrain de chasse en fait on fait la
même chose bon c'est pas content comme
ça procure un grand un grand plaisir
surtout quand on le fait en groupe c'est
ça qui vous plaît dans cette eco trail
le parcours oui le parc où il est très
nature c'est très nature encore une fois
ange c'est la chasse modèle sur
l'intérêt de la chasse anciennes donc
c'est très bien fait et les gens et
beaucoup de gens qui me disent j'aime le
13 je n'ai pas le marathon parce que
c'est la coutume mais en fait nous
sommes nous sommes une espèce animale et
donc on se retrouve dans la nature
mais ma promenade on le trouve le
collège si en plus on trime découvrir
donc le bonheur est complet alors vous
êtes un coureur jeu si vous n'aimez pas
le terme un peu atypique car vous
courrez pieds nus la plupart du temps je
les marathons ou les ultra marathon est
ce que vous allez courir pieds nus sur
ce rendez vous euh non parce que c'est
pas très conseillé jusqu'à je ne suis
pas encore prêt nous en être un autre
milieu d'année était pieds nus
mais moi j'ai porté des chaussures comme
vous comme tout le monde pendant
plusieurs décennies et ensuite on se met
à courir pieds nus c'est un peu le début
difficile et à ce stade là
sur le bitume je peux courir j'écoule 90
km 1 afrique du sud
ça ce qu'un problème contrairement au
cou la chaussée
mais dans la forêt
d'abord je vois pas en fait je suis pas
prêt je ne suis pas prêt pour le faire
et a toujours un peu de risques dans la
nature nos ancêtres qui coule des
risques mais ils n'avaient pas de choix
parce qu'il n'avait pas de chaussures il
fallait qu'ils mangent mais nous on a le
choix en fait on peut essayer de devenir
comme eux mais de façon pragmatique
là où on peut faire exactement comme eux
on le fait s'il nous faut un minimum de
protection
millions de protection donc je vais
courir avec des chaussures minimalistes
merci sidy diallo merci d'être intervenu
sur cette émission vous comptez faire à
peu près intel entend de combien sur
cette eco trail vous savez ou pas du
tout
c'est la première fois que je fais les
45 km le il faut je crois que la
barrière aurait fc 19 15 je veux aller
vers 19h15
avant de nuancer
et puis je vais essayer de profiter au
maximum de la course et s1j avec les
autres couleurs et c'est ça l'essentiel
merci beaucoup si diallo vous souhaite
un bon trail ce samedi je le rappelle
vous allez participer aux 45 km de l'eco
trail merci à vous on va on va terminer
par du golfe la billetterie du prochain
open de france de golf est désormais
ouverte le rendez-vous sera organisée du
22 au 25 septembre sur les greens du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines cette 104e édition qui aura une
dotation de 3 millions d'euros devrait
attirer des stars de la discipline et
notamment des têtes d'affiché françaises
comme victor perez ou encore le
versailles et antoine ros meneur au
rendez-vous fêtera également son grand
retour et n'a pas été programmé depuis
2010 neuf à cause de la crise sanitaire
c'est la fin de cette émission à merci
de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
2 non